hey guys it's justine and i'm here with
my friend ro hello we haven't done a
video in a while together i know it's
been too long i was so happy you came
over because i was so sad when i found
out that we were gonna be doing a video
together i brought over
this mystery bag i love mystery bags so
i have been like wondering what's in
here i love mystery like everything like
even mystery gum well this isn't really
a mystery to me because i bought all of
these i wanted to do a video talking
about some of the weirdest ugliest
iphone cases that i could find some of
these in here are just idiots i can't
wait for you to see them do you want to
go first yes
okay
this one's like it's actually very
fitting for you
oh my gosh it's a door
it could potentially be cookie with
glasses i think i have a knife in here i
have a punisher knife
careful
look at that
you always have the coolest knife i love
knives okay how do you do this you just
just
whoa
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh so this is our first one this one is
actually a nice case i like this yeah
so the dog could have had a happier face
though you think criticism number one i
really have no attachment to any of
these cases so you can be negative or
positive does this dog face
look happy he looks like he's moderately
excited about life let's put this little
puppy on there okay you can just tell us
in the comments if you like it or don't
like it yeah so is it cute or is it woof
i must say some of these were very
extremely um
very cheap so
crazy oh
popcorn popcorn is it squishy yeah it's
almost like the same thing oh i like
this texture who would get this as like
you were a movie enthusiast this is not
very well made like i can't even get in
there to like turn the volume off let's
try another one yeah let's try another
one i'm going to pretend one of those
machines the claws
can you guys see what it is because i
don't know yet i know what this one is
it's what the heck is this is this like
a a lint ball
just open it up and see oh geez
okay so i really gotta hold on better
yeah just
oh how do you do this away from the face
it's cut away
okay oh my goodness
oh it's an animal
oh my
okay
this is where to begin where do we begin
there's glue on the side of this there
is glue you have to see this can you see
this this is disgusting justine please
model this glue can you
that's a butt
no
i designed a butt
no no no no
what is this
oh my goodness
this is not his face this is not his
face okay so this is the face
this is the back side of a cat yeah so i
saw this and then i saw that so this is
like his booty area oh my goodness
somebody did not get neutered
yeah did you not out of spain
the warning from bob barker back in the
day can you imagine if i showed up to
your house like this oh hey justine girl
let's um let's just take a selfie can
you imagine so it is this is actually
foul like i can't even look at it like
my finger
is touching things and probably
shouldn't touch you're so close to them
it does kind of make a good you know
like one of those pop sockets here let's
take care of this
let me do let me here can you hold this
down for me i just i don't want to cut
you but like you just hold right there
justine is now a veterinarian she is
performing surgery as we speak
it's a little bit more appropriate
i feel so uncomfortable i'm like
sticking my hand in here this is
definitely not where i thought this
video was gonna go this is really crappy
i need to look how much i need to see
how much i paid for this because this is
definitely
not worth anything at all i can't even
believe that someone would buy this
custom handmade the glue i mean this is
custom this is hand glued soft fur case
cartoon funny cute puppy plush animal
cat butt corgi tail brown hair creative
design apple 10
10 phone case for girls women gray cat i
can't believe this what a title this
one's nice and catchy eight dollars
sticks with you and 99 this yes okay we
need a discount now whatever is making
this clean up the glue a little i'm
going to go through and i'm going to
leave some reviews for each one of these
i also like how the glue is yellow
because it kind of looks like maybe it
was like
peepee
take that off of your phone immediately
are you ready for the next one
take it away
oh
this one looks really cool oh
okay this is a cool one okay what camera
is it that's the s100 there's not a lot
to read in here no this is called iphoto
camera case
it's definitely
uh
it feels really cheap what does it feel
like is it oh but look at all these
little knobs that oh they don't turn oh
see it looks like you could probably put
like a little i don't know
but like a little does this do something
no
it looks like you can put like a little
hanger type thing on it you could make
it a purse you could we have string do
we have ribbon does it feel okay if it's
pretty good can you hit your buttons hit
the button button yeah
although i definitely can't get to the
one to put it on vibrate so
that's definitely not good
oh oops
oh it's broken
i mean i just did a simple turn oh shoot
i already broke the second one i mean i
could jam it back in we need super glue
and strength
let's see what else we need another
great iphone case all right what else we
got in here hello
did i get another animal butt you did
okay what butt is this i am lucking out
justine i'm getting all the little booty
cheeks i got another little animal booty
cheek i hope this is a little bit better
made you can guess what animal it is
i think it's a cocky butt
i think it is too i think it's yeah
look at underneath this is much more
appropriate there's no private parts
hanging out so this is a lot cuter this
is really soft too oh my gosh my new pop
socket this one's a little bit better
than the other one because the other one
definitely was very it was very
uncomfortable there may be another case
in here that you're going to like even
more than that this is just weird not
great
oh what
what the ear already broke
the quality of these ears is very
astounding interesting
guess what we've got look wait is it my
turn yeah
i found two booties in a row
what is this
i don't actually even remember ordering
this is that what i think it is it's
pink panther yes oh my gosh
that is a throwback that is a retro
cartoon i used to watch i mean that is
what do you think pink panther's up to
now i think it like was made into a
movie a really long time ago but i can't
remember now i like no clue he's really
just sticking out of this case he's
really fancy he's got a top hat this is
like a diy case gone wrong this actually
looks kind of good from far away
yeah i feel like he's going to start to
like tap dance and did he's happening
what did he do
he was
he
wait didn't he the one the song was like
that's pink panther isn't it
i thought so
is he a spy the pink panther is a
british american media franchise company
primarily focusing on a series of comedy
mystery films featuring a french police
detective inspector
okay this is too much information anyway
um detective this is a pretty good
it's a pretty nice phone case do any of
you guys know who pink panther is is
this is this too too old for you or
because this said it was like in 1963.
okay we didn't watch it in 1963
okay just for the record before we go
there we didn't watch it in the 16th we
did it okay on to the next one
what is it oh it is really creepy
i thought just looking through i thought
it was like pills but don't be fools
they're small people they're people
inside of they look like little pill
capsules talk about pop socket you can
just stick your fingers in there that's
kind of cool and just like hold it ooh
can they open no i think that's probably
asking a lot this is bizarre because
some of the people are standing up some
are like bent over like they're sitting
down what is this
they're like matrix pills with people
inside
[Applause]
oh
it's so cute oh weird
it's huge that's like an ipad case
this is so massive that's for your phone
yes i could fit an ipad that could fit a
small ipad it's so big
like look at look at your phone look at
this an inch and a half bigger yeah and
then look how much bigger it is on this
side like how would you what if you had
to keep a little clutch how would you
where would you put this oh it's steak
oh gosh this smells like poison
smells like gas it stinks it smells like
like like when you're doing a barbecue
propane propane oh i know something
about propane
[Music]
what we have
oh
are you kidding me it's a unicorn that's
perfect for you except for this is the
fact that it is the size of your body
this i would hurt myself wow okay i like
that a little bit i have a hard time
pushing any of the buttons clearly or
not very functional and if you're like
laying in bed okay justine you're gonna
be my boyfriend okay we're laying in bed
and i'm like you know scrolling on the
phone and i should be going to bed but
i'm like scrolling if i drop this on my
face which i usually do this could take
out his eye it could yeah it could take
out your eye unicorn is super cute but
little i'm a little at this point
there's no rainbow made oh i'm sorry i
mean i probably want to come with a
couple extra colors and why is it just
white these clearly are not high quality
maybe there's something else in here
oh what is it it's a pen okay that's
cute oh let me see this knife yeah open
this puppy up
okay look at this this is so cute
i like it
i love it okay i'm definitely keeping
this one on
this is my favorite one and it's like
small low profile um i think we have how
many more is that we got one more
do i get do it yeah it's your turn
what's it gonna be
[Music]
what was wrong
what is this
so weird what am i looking at
okay so
i already know what this is i do not
know what this is and i don't even know
if i wanna know what this is is this a
chicken wing
this is a crunch i was like is this poop
barf what is this
the best part about this is they have
like five different shapes of chicken
they've got like a chicken tender a
chicken
yes it's so
weird this also said it was an iphone 10
case but they clearly you know i think
it was the other thing
no it's definitely it's definitely not
this is a seven plus i have to give it
credit because it actually out of the
packaging looks like chicken it does i
just can't believe that there's several
different like i was gonna call them
flavors but there's different chicken
shapes these are like those fake foods
when you're a little kid and you get the
ones that are really realistic looking
like little fake foods to play with i
don't know what time is up a lot of room
in your purse i like fashion but i'm
also a fan of functionality so
waste
wasting space not
oh my gosh can you just stick it on
anywhere you can stick it anywhere i
mean it was just glued on
this is disgusting who would ever i
can't even i can't even think about like
if someone's like this is what i want my
if you were going to design a
custom case what do you think you would
put on it well piggy i really like the
pig or this is just so silly like i
can't get over it that was the last one
oh that's it yes i'm sorry these were so
weird and awesome which one do you think
is your favorite this is so hard for me
these little booty cheek ones
shocked me this one was the weirdest to
me so strange little people in pill
capsules i don't get it and that was
just so weird i this is for you
wow i love when friends give you great
gifts
if anyone was wondering what justine got
me uh
when we hit 10 million subscribers it
was this chicken wing let's see
rose 10 million subscribers with this
chicken wing but you know what you want
to keep any of the other ones like
honestly you totally can will people
think like your dexter creepy if you
have this
i mean i don't think they're gonna
really really see it until they actually
look at it let's show these all off can
you see all of the these this is like
you need to see all of it in all of its
glory bro thanks so much for being in my
video today
this is awesome make sure you guys go
check out ro's channel i'll put a link
in the description and be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell on both of
our channels we'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]